um
[Applause]
apologies
someone willing to move to be accepted
you should worship
moved in second
second put it to the bottle and forever
say aye bye against carried
declaration of interests
any changes there
you public forum
no one
from the
public is attending wanting to speak
major light late items
you worship there are three major late
items
the first is the minutes of the risk and
assurance committee held on the 16th of
december which had not been prepared at
the time the agenda was distributed
the second item is the receipt of the
annual report which
we believe will be ready to come back to
you later this afternoon so we'd ask
that you receive it as a late item and
the third item is a matter from the
extraordinary risk and assurance meeting
held just earlier
which will be in public excluded and
that is the mattershed bolton
icc thank you remember that anyone wish
to move that they'd be accepted as load
items
thank you
i'll second that
so the minutes of meeting the council
yeah i don't think so
we're up to there or we're
move to the minutes of the council held
on the 23rd of november 2021
be confirmed
moved your worship secretary
discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
move on the report on the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting
the performance policy and partnerships
committee
if they be received your worship second
after your worship i'm being moved and
seconded i'm sorry your worship ms cook
can't second the item
i understand ms cook thank you
councillor lewis
councillors you're agreeing to
thank you
any questions discussion put it to the
vote all in favor say aye aye against
carried
remove the minutes of the
infrastructural services committee held
on the 7th of december
i'll move 21. i'll move that your
worship and the recommendations
included
thank you to move second
council out there
discussion questions
put it to the voice all in favor say hi
that's what popping your head
oh
counselor
um look as as chair of that committee i
just like as information to other
counsellors
speaking to my
equivalent colleague in christchurch
when the
mou was put in front of the christchurch
city council
they voted 10 3
and adopted the mou for the three waters
thing so i just thought i'd pass on that
piece of information thank you
thank you for that
any further questions discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
moved at the minutes of the bluff
community board meeting held on the 13th
of december i'll move those minutes
thank you
seconder for that i'll second that
moved and seconded question discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carried
uh
we received
the minutes of the performance policy
and partnerships committee
held on the 14th of december 2021. move
that's received your worship
on second natural worship and the
recommendations
i would just ask that you
are deliberate in the recommendations to
council given the
nature of the changes that are being
recommended there
any further questions discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
all right
carried
now have a set of recommendations to
council
uh councillor ludlow moved those when he
moved the receipt as did councillor
lewis in second
it's been moved and seconded any further
questions discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
it's been done with this oh it's been
done
what about that
sorry they've all been done so
a bit of a short cut there but
uh
well done
move on to the
mid report
i'll move did it be received secondary
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
against carried
uh in these the minutes of the
you know your worship is the minutes of
the risk insurance committee held on the
16th of december
and that goes well that was a late item
and it's now available to be
moved as being received
okay so we can move to receive that as a
late item
you've moved that already if you just
like to put the minutes
move to the
mover and the second to
the minutes be received
i'll move that
stephen did your worship thank you moved
and seconded
discussion questions counselor partner
thank you worship look just regarding um
health and safety risk update
there and talks about the um
the vaccine uh double vaccine required
look i'm just wondering and this is this
applies to a lot of businesses around
invercargill there's the
health and safety risk to
the potential health and safety risk to
staff who
have to wear masks for a continued
period of time
and i do feel sorry for any staff
anywhere who have to do this because of
their role so i just wanted is that
something that we've actually
investigated the actual impact of of
wearing masks for duration
um on on members um on staff
you know the potential you know health
consequences because it's not it is not
normal yeah
uh mr chair i think that i'd be able to
comment that wearing masks
is not something that is
enjoyed by individuals however for most
staff of council it is a
but a fleeting period of time in the
context of the
hours of the week for those who are in
public facing roles at all times such as
in the library and the customer service
centre it is without doubt an
inconvenience
but i think the science is clear that it
is
a positive step that one can take
for themselves and for those around them
and i note that the disposable masks
that many of us are wearing are actually
made for medical use where they could be
worn for a much longer period than most
of us are experiencing i think we see it
as an appropriate risk mitigation step
albeit an inconvenient one
thank you
that i'll put my mask back on
the question was raised as to whether or
not
uh
we're on duty during the holiday period
and
i feel we're always on duty if we're
in the city at the time
we had a case where a young student was
killed in the car crash at the turn-off
to milford
uh on the way to
in the city
and
myself and the
penny were just hopped in a car and
drove out to the site
to console the parents and
you just never know what
can happen
in a situation like that and i like to
think that
we would all make ourselves available in
the event of
a tragic such as that
answer
it's just just a reflection to that um
at cheers today
um it was a decided that uh council
londo
and councillor pottenger who
um aren't taking leave over that period
would would cover that
um experience has taught me in the last
12 months that sometimes being on duty
but not answering yourself i
uh can put council in a difficult
position so
it's good that this year we've
designated a couple of people
l comes before pain
here's the questions discussion
we would just um we need to put that to
the vote to worship it's sweet
[Music]
okay we have a mover in secondary
minutes of the risk and assurance
committee
fear the questions
not i'll put it to the vote all in favor
say aye aye
against carried
in your report now you worship the
advice i have is that
the annual report should be the auditors
should be in a position to attend
council within the next
20 to 30 minutes
uh mr day is going to give us an update
thank you through your self-worship um
just another update hot off the press it
is more looking like five o'clock before
we get the hard copy pack to us i just
wanted to alert the council
so if council was to move into public
excluded at this stage and do the
matters on the public excluded agenda
it could deal with that matter and
uh the outstanding business
on ppp
uh with a view to coming back to
council and the risk and assurance and
then council in relation to the receipt
of the annual report
move that we go into public excluded
with the exception of mr grant and mr
mckenzie
your worship
moved and seconded discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye